hello and welcome to for 30-something
guys making fun of the princess movie
long take that princess trailer our
thought process behind it if you stick
around afterwards you'll see some
deleted scenes will respond to comments
from viewers like you and we will show
some a tease for next week's trailer
which is gonna be a fun one y'all
actually I know I said we're gonna make
fun of it I really like this movie I
missed her when it came out I did not
know much about it and I thought it was
a delight mm-hmm I would rank it up
there with my favorite Disney movies yep
I like it now very favorite all-time top
tier top 10 Wow
top 10 tangled yeah there were some
folks saying they were doing some honest
trailer fact-checking and they went back
to our frozen trailer five years ago and
said that we contradicted ourselves
because of the trailer for frozen we
said it's been three years since the
last is a musical and that was actually
tangled mm-hmm and we said and eighteen
years since the last good Disney musical
yes so they say that we're playing both
sides because we said that in five years
ago with a different writing team except
for a couple of people that that frozen
was better well for my response to that
they'll have to wait till after we watch
yeah I don't know I really like the the
villain mom relationship with her I
thought that was like an interesting
choice for Disney who usually presents
mothers and such a good light and to
kind of twist that and turn that on its
head yeah I thought it was cool
I thought the animation did a good job
kind of blending 3d in storybook and
like if they didn't fully Shrek it they
didn't put like you know Jeffrey
Katzenberg jokes in there but they still
gave it a more modern sense of humor
yeah what else you got Joe we wore the
same shirt again today I didn't see when
it came out just one theatrically either
for whatever reason was in my late 20s
or early 30s or not that may have been
part of it yeah but no I think I think
it's how I feel - its it does a good job
of balancing being a little bit funnier
a little bit more tongue-in-cheek or
kind of snarky but not too far to where
it feels like a parody or enchanted or
so like it's still it's doing the thing
that it's making fun yes the horse is
funny all the characters are like a boat
yeah it's kind of small but funny role
for Paul if Tompkins he's got a dream
well before this analysis gets too deep
and hard-hitting let's watch it for its
angles it's worth funny horse funny
funny [ __ ] tompkins good hair long
fall down do you good maybe I watch on
Plus
he spent years working on a classic 2d
animated Rapunzel movie but when
princess in the frog bra and Shrek sword
a box of his Heights King Eisner decreed
they start over with a joke field CGI
ROM for girls and boys alike
and you know what it's better than
frozen come at me haters pause so I'm
sure I fully but well okay I'll save
again my response to that person but I'm
really sad that they took that lesson
from Princess and the Frog but like will
never make another 2d and may I film
again Marie I think the timeline might
be a little off there how so I felt I
think Princess Farah came out like 2009
and this movie came out 2010 so I guess
it would have been it would have been
fairly deep into the feel like she a
cutie this before comedies there you
watch her stuff I just okay I was just
now thinking of that numbers hat on yeah
fair enough it's fair but you know just
like the sonic movie they really mated
that in like a month
so because the bridges the Frog is not a
huge blockbuster on the size of their
others that they didn't seem to
completely abandon the 2d through that
old era it's a lot more expensive and
time-consuming to do the 2d animated
films versus this style and did this
this was what I was becoming more
popular it's what kids were getting into
it was only natural there was one movie
or but not more of a trend I do think
that the the lesson that should have
come from Princess and the Frog and the
only lesson was that if you were going
to do a movie set in New Orleans and
fill it with jazz that Randy Newman does
not do your songs also also
[Music]
[Applause]
okay or seen that movie so it looks
pretty though
so you can do any Chandra yeah I wish
she had dense Straight Outta Compton I
mean pause we can just briefly touch on
it that village are gone completely
thatched-roof cottages yes and everybody
you know in the bay but next to the
village setting off all these lanterns
that's like a siege warfare tactic one
of them's gonna get caught on something
like every other block or so it's like
the beginning of Robin Hood Men in
Tights where they're like didn't make
the trailer yeah a little too granular
but also the idea of the whole impetus
for this is that Rapunzel wants to know
why every year on her birthday they set
these lights out she's like it's a sign
every year and my birthday yeah I mean
like if your mother Gothel why wouldn't
you tell them that her birthday is like
three months later just like what about
today it said like it's you're busted
child like nothing you could also just
not even tell
about the control all the information
she gets in the world lately room her in
the gas lighting and you know we didn't
get in the use of too old boy as a verb
when you someone you're just a revenge
based old bullying you know that's true
it was just it's an opportunity to stick
old boy right also that was a bad army
the kingdom that thing that tower was
like within running distance yes very
close and and it's not like miss it's
not hidden by magic it's not behind some
vine it looks like a pretty big it's a
pretty tall good mr. criminal career
criminals bumbled his way into it and I
wonder if it's like people in this city
are just very snobby and they're just
like Oh walking up to that tower it's a
lot one flower on a cliff yeah they
don't even know where to look because
it's like a totalitarian state that was
like forced labor they got every single
person to leave their homes yeah and you
got a finger like back Rapunzel truther
I'm saying I'd say that they they
abandoned her for a reason that the king
and queen never say a word in the entire
film which is creepy
I find that yeah they never say anything
they just maybe they have like a psychic
link controlling everybody and there's a
few like pregnant moments where you're
like oh now we're gonna hear them too
and then they purposefully don't like
they cut away before they have a chance
to you scratch the surface what I'm
saying is there's more underneath here
Rapunzel yeah
follow the clues are the lanterns
chemtrails she's not a witch it's gonna
be the first time at Disney sidekick
murders I think that this is like a big
argument for like yeah this stuff's
definitely for kids cuz the older I get
the more I sympathize with like some of
the villains or I stop funding them as
ugly and pretty Ursula can get it you
know I'm just getting older my taster
refining don't judge me Spencer no I'm
not judging you know that's that was the
point we're making is like sure it's
kidnapping sure it's ver she has her own
motives to keep her trapped in a tower
and I slid to broom her to Oldboy her
she has her moves at the same time she's
never met a man before in her life the
only man she meets is a liar and a thief
yeah and he's 26 it's true she marries
him over the course of nine days a week
and change christmas break yeah thief
like he stole some bread like he's not a
Jean Valjean thief
grand theft yeah complete narcissist
he's his biggest complaint is that they
got his nose wrong on the wanted posters
skies uh I'm not into 19 feet on set
like that guy yeah he's a real zero yeah
yeah he's a big ol zero
I believe I Gotham was right was right
specifically about this one thing a lot
of letters yes we put a lot of pressure
I am assuming it's the same in a magical
kingdom as it is in Hollywood but we
love we put a lot of pressure on the
aging process for women over 30 and 40
right you know she's gonna have to go to
him extreme Ledger's to stay I mean who
was accusing her of being a witch for
mere moments ago you know this is these
are the societal pressures on you know
aging epilady with magic hair if they
did make her witch it would explain the
tower being hurt maybe they should have
made her a witch cuz then they could've
been like well she's hiding the tower
with magic right you had a good point on
that they are functionally no different
from using Rapunzel is no different from
the Queen Rapunzel's mom also bogarting
that flower son puts a flower for
anybody to use it can heal them or make
them young forever great and then the
king and queen shut it down and make it
into a juice given to just the Queen and
then it's just first and no one else
could use forever that's worse than what
gospel does to old boy a juice then to
old boy take your smiley taking it from
the whole world like no and this
could've killed millions of people and
as being used to save one burst of
healed death yeah mortal or you could
save this one lady's dog you gotta
figure everyone died in childbirth back
then it was like cool thing to do it's
not even that rare but they're like nope
no more in your more immunity for the
entire world from everything you can't
have a monarchy and universal health
care you know
you gotta have a plate come through
there and then there was like leeches
and a donkey kick for donkey kicks and a
prayer
alright let's get going Robert sunlight
and call me really fights that horse
this is my favorite set up lines we've
ever written anything if we're gonna see
man yeah that's just the default
[Music]
that a food bark that is the gasoline
pond a lot of daily routine side
they pause there was debate of the
Gaston yeah we got some coincidence at
in there all right right now because
it's time
purple iguana rights you guys put Gaston
in the guys with the soft side montage
what was Gaston soft side he's clearly
very modest and that's we're saying
objectively these villains have soft
sides we're saying this is the song
where it's like hey like they're not
even villain songs but they're like
don't don't be scared of this character
he shows up on screen like don't judge
it they're all like don't judge a book
by it's cover like this guy looks like a
real tough bad man he's still being a
real but in this song but the point of
it is like it's cuz he's awesome I'm
awesome and that makes me a great dudes
perspective the song is about why he's
so likable not why he's a bad guy it
makes him look like a buffoon like but
also these are all bonuses these are all
pluses yeah and look I'm changing who
I'm attracted to you I'm getting old I
never want to talk about sexual issues a
lot of them wow so many of these
but someone actually put the chords in
the comments good for that Dan like that
that's the Macarena anyways the point is
I could do it I remember the first four
moves of the Macarena they did like yeah
they sent him like four times is like
[Music]
not the most memorable stuff and I'll
make it like he's great it's fine he has
plenty other heads I see the lights seem
to be the one that most people push back
on like that's the best song ever it's
fine you know what guys we picked
tangled and then we forgot about the
song part and get off our butts didn't
forget about it I didn't really thought
the like okay we could parody these
things that no one remembers right you
know there's clearly the strong version
is way better it's the same song it's
like the witch singing to Rapunzel and
you know he's been around alright
except for the nonsensical ending where
your tears can suddenly heal the sick
that is unless you're familiar with the
source material where Rapunzel's tears
cure blindness since her prince couches
own eyes grabs very German
so a young blonde girl with a wreath in
her hair takes a birthday trip with her
shady boyfriend to witness an annual
ritual jokes for the 12 people who saw
both tangled and midsummer and for them
are in this table it's still fun
let's roll right into some deleted
scenes before we come on to hair which
yeah
Danielle with the excellent joke this
yeah there you go those things didn't
make it in we're we just talking in the
bathroom about things we wish we'd said
oh yeah always good any given day yeah
nine day fiancé
nine-day fiance of always yours oh we
were trying to do a Dashboard
Confessional parody about like your hair
being everywhere yeah sorry
alright well let's talk y'all Paul
Rutherford don't put your fall Greg
Rutherford don't put your full name in
your youtube name this is your best
trailer yet thank you so good great work
yes thank you for doing it Wow that's it
for honest trailer commentaries better
than frozen yes so glad to see some
appreciation for tangled can't wait for
your commentary to hear why you wrote
that line this is true so this is where
we'll talk about why did you say earlier
he said in the honest trailer for frozen
we said it's been three years since lest
is a musical in eighteen years since the
last good one yeah I haven't agreed that
well so I can answer just as someone who
worked on both I will just say number
one I hadn't seen tangled sometimes it
makes [ __ ] out
right
just as an editor yeah and then the
second of all having now I'm going to
back my way into an explanation that
frozen is a better musical songs are
better tangled better film overall I
will definitely take the music of frozen
any day over the music
I agree tangle better movie frozen
better music so if you want to strictly
judge it on a musical basis I do think
frozen is better there you go rappers
fun the last song we are making ice good
song yeah yeah there's not a song called
we are making ice let go
as overplayed as it was is like it's
null time I can hello so yeah so anyways
that's my response to that's worth like
four songs if not for frozen not gonna
try rancis I'll just say exactly if I
fan 69 writes so you don't mention
Zachary Levi he deserves to be a
household name
I think he's close we didn't mention
more I there by name yeah he hears
you're exactly if I mentioned he's a
delight I like him in this film I like
his junk I like him in like him in for
yeah first one or the second one this is
the guy who's in the first door
Thorndike friends yes Chloe Lewis writes
why did he sound so incredibly cheery in
this honest trailer this is just what
John does in his his Disney ones he's
yes he's imitating other professional
trailer vo people and this is like the
Disney House style back when they used
to have voices in their trailers was
this is what it sounds like if you watch
his 80s 90s action movies he's doing
like the dumb Lafon same exact refill
British ething for like Harry Potter and
some other stuff like that
Jedi making up right why was frozen more
popular this is clearly the superior
film what do y'all think
music music music some things they get a
momentum you know when something becomes
a phenomenon other people want to see it
because it's a phenomena yeah I also
think before frozen the narrative on
Disney weirdly still on animated
musicals was like oh and now they're
just trying to do Shrek you know like
kind of like they weren't because now
post frozen it's like oh of course
Disney does the best animated movies but
I think there was another weird like
dark period pocket there's a very dark
animation time right and this was after
but it was right after the the Pixar
merger where they like poach someone to
then run Disney Animation from Pixar so
everything like brave when that Disney
movie yeah yeah like they started to
become more pics re and like then I
think frozen is where they arrived it
like the best of both worlds now
yourself
there was like modern Black Cauldron
yeah
there's always those like it just
computers where like the industry is
changing in animation and tastes are
changing it all kind of happens at once
and then they have to like re you know
direct everything and you know this was
sort of the movie where they kind of
started to like figure it out and then
froze and really moved it in the new
direction well there you go also
Rapunzel and Eugene are in frozen
they're at the wedding they are indeed
really diverse I have I had a theory
because looking at the Rapunzel's
village it was like the Dorne of the it
looks like the dawn of of wherever Elsa
lives it was looked warmer like like it
was a warmer climate everything's
similarities yeah I wonder like it she's
from like south of whatsits we're like
Lannisport
you know if the Western is a Casterly
Rock Dornish field or the swingers
Highgarden we did not get a good look at
that festival you don't know what
happens with all right those are your
questions and these are our responses so
if we hope you enjoyed them why don't
you come back for next week when we'll
be doing whatever it takes to bring you
that honest trailer no matter who we
have to kill well not kill but you know
mean it's not worse you'll see you'll
all see thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed on Australian comforters bye bye
you